[Music]
so let's talk about that mob for a
second because I sense that both sides
right now are being led by their mob I
see it more on the left but I do see it
on the right as well that's just the
hysterical people who have all the
magical answers who have if it was only
their Messiah so the hysterical people
on the right they have their Messiah in
office right now but the hysterical
people on the left that if they only had
Bernie it would all be okay
the middle it's hard to get that middle
mob to get going right was very
difficult to be deeply committed to
moderation so Yates has that poem where
he says the worst are full of passionate
intensity while the best lack all
conviction because you think well this
is actually hard there's a bunch of
people think it's not her they know
exactly what to do and politics if it's
going to work needs to have rules
institutions constitutions that prevent
them from being able to control the
government and that's the the genius of
what our Constitution has done that
separation of powers I understand it's
really frustrating because it means that
there you feel strongly there seems to
be majority in favor of it and yet we
still can't do it because the president
doesn't go along the Supreme Court
doesn't go along it means that a lot of
times the status quo is privileged but
the alternative is to have a mob and
Plato when he thought of democracy
actually talked about too much Liberty
means that you've got the butler's that
are drunk on on Liberty's heady wine
right and that they'll say if they find
a leader who doesn't give them too much
they'll call them black curds and
oligarchs that you should do exactly
what we want well they don't actually
know what what they want so we have a
real problem in and this is an
interesting paradox in democracy there
was a famous Englishman that said the
reason that we put our leaders heads on
stamps is that we can thumb their noses
and lick their Hydra parks we have both
of those attitudes towards leaders we
want them to be better than us and to do
what we say yeah
part of this also that we think that we
need to get our morals from our leaders
too and maybe that's changing a little
bit with Trump but that we thought that
you know they always want you're going
to be married you can have the perfect
family we're going to show you the kids
we know that it's always a fraud and
Merrill cheating on their wives and
doing all sorts of awful things but that
we've tried to make our politicians and
to be perfect humans which again is the
messiah thing you're talking about but
it's just it's just show sure it's
difficult we have other things you know
there's basketball to watch there's
baseball there's picnics to go on we
don't really want to have to watch
politicians very closely and so we
substitute I was really surprised at
this how little voters knew or cared
about actual issues the issue that I is
a political scientist I want to talk
about that right now they're going I got
to go really not interested in that at
all no but it's an important issue yeah
I'm out I'm sorry yeah what they're
interested instead is your character so
if your character is very much like them
it means that you'll go off and when
they're not watching they'll do what
they would have done you will do what
they would have done right and so they
want you to know are you like me in
terms of core values yeah and that's why
family and things like that matter is
that you're a good person now it the
problem is what Trump is a strange
misnomer in that isn't he he said the
things that many white people believed
Trump won a majority of white women I
think that's the single most astonishing
fact about this election
Trump won a majority of white women and
the reason is that the Democrats for
reasons that I have a hard time
understanding mostly campaigned on a
platform of white people suck you guys
are privileged you and there's all sorts
of reasons why actually you can say that
that's true but as a political strategy
it didn't work and so Clinton when she
said why am I not ahead by 50 points
yeah it's amazing that they didn't
recognize that they had actually to
appeal to a majority of Americans not to
try to put together a coalition of
disparate interest groups that are
united by nothing except the promise
that they're going to get paid off
so that goes directly to social justice
which I talk about all the time I assume
you see this as a pretty big threat to
the way our political system should work
right it sounds good social justice but
in in reality its it's creating these
competing interests that have to sort of
knock each other down a peg we're all in
favor of justice and social justice
means that we have a system that works I
see social justice as the claim that
there shouldn't be any unearned
privilege and to the extent that people
think they've been denied something
that's where this social justice warrior
impulse comes from it's particularly
interesting being on college campuses to
see what social justice warriors have
done where they would even allow other
people to speak and so there's a there's
a broad problem of free speech and
social justice and then the problem on
college campuses that I have to deal
with often personally yeah the the
social justice warriors and academic
freedom which is a little bit different
from free freedom of speech academic
freedom is a different concept but the
the social justice impulse to the extent
that it's a number of people have said
but I think Milton Friedman said it if
you take money from a and give it to B
it's likely B will vote for you that
doesn't mean that it's the right thing
to do just campaigning with other
people's money
yeah and so all of us are clever we can
come up with reasons why you should get
something and you should get something
and you should get something but at some
point you run out of other people's
money yeah and you just split now this
thing into a gajillion editing's so
discussing this on the campus
front how bad is it on campuses right
now I talked to professors all sorts of
different disciplines and almost
everybody says it's pretty terrible I'm
really spoiled because I'm a Duke so I
mean you probably heard about how bad
Charles Murray's visit to Duke was
probably didn't because it was fine
we had Charles Murray in oh wait which
was the one thing you got me there which
was the one that it was the hole yeah
justice it
whether there there was a number of
places that charles Murray try out okay
okay I got up turned out really badly he
came to Duke there were three idiots
with booze in the room was quite you
couldn't even hear it yeah it was fine
people asked some questions in fact I
asked that they asked more rude
questions he's a grown-up yeah happy to
answer agressive rude questions so I
think that the answer is I have an odd
view probably I'm a big fan of safe
spaces yeah so you wrote I wanted to ask
about it so you wrote a piece on unlearn
liberty in defense of safe spaces which
as I read it you parse it to a point
that actually makes some sense to me
because I'm not a safe space guy so take
it away well it's an attempt at judo
obviously I'm using safe space in a way
where people who are in favor of safe
spaces they go yeah yeah wait what right
so you kind of flip it so can you
well it to me the the main principle
universities are operating on is not
freedom of speech we can say anything
you want but academic freedom which
means that you can go up into little
groups and be insulated from people that
you disagree with so you can work on
something so the political scientists
are working on something in a particular
way in sociology is working on something
in a particular way we have communities
of scholars that work on things and in
our talks there's a bunch of things that
are shared premises shared assumptions
and we're going to try to advance
without constantly having to confront
all of the other possible ways of
thinking about this right so so you're
describing that as a safe space but I
feel like that's not exactly what the
like I don't know that many people would
argue that that isn't okay right even
the people that are first Apes well but
the then we can go on to raise the
question and Van Jones has this amazing
video where he makes exactly the right
argument I think what you cannot do is
annex the entire university as a safe
space mm-hmm you cannot say I want to be
all across the university safe from
anything that I disagree with so that
it's the very fact that there's these
different safe spaces that
really ensure there's going to be
somebody working on things you totally
disagree with and they have to be safe
within that space you don't get to
prevent them from doing that so I think
we need safe spaces for examples for
fraternities and that's doesn't know the
safe space people our net deficit we
pretended hated areas that no people
need to be able to come up with
associations so there's five freedoms
that are guaranteed in the First
Amendment and we forget freedom of
association freedom Association means I
get to choose the people that I hang out
with and if I want to have a club or
organization and we have rules and we
want to talk about the stuff we want to
talk about in having the speakers that
we want even if it's my luck mm-hmm okay
but people seem to be lost on its I mean
I got confused I see even with the
guests that we choose here if I choose
one person someone will love me for a
year then I put on one person who they
don't like
suddenly they prescribed all of that
person's beliefs on to me I go well I
was just asking them question and and
listening to the answers and you can
either turn it off or maybe you'll learn
something yeah John Stuart Mill has this
great idea of Education where he says it
requires collision with air and the way
I try to explain it to people is I think
this happens much more on the left that
a lot of the young students on the Left
have just learned one move chess
openings they move the pawn in front of
their king out to spaces and then
they're patted on the head it's good
yeah and somebody knows a five move
chess opening in response they're really
upset can you do that well you must be a
bad person in fact we're going to
prevent that because I don't know why
your argument is false the only possible
explanation is that it's evil
yeah is that your racist bigoted
homophobic setter because they've never
actually had to confront people that
they disagreed with yeah so collision
with error means that you're constantly
trying to improve your own views because
if you find someone you disagree with
one of two things is true either you're
right but you don't know the reasons and
you should think about it because not
knowing the reasons is a lot like not
knowing the truth
memorizing some catechism of truths is
not what college is about it's learning
reasons and being able to reason
critically yeah
you can't do that unless you know the
best argument against your position so
one of the things I'm pretty judgmental
about this I'll ask people
that's an interesting claim what do you
think is the best counter-argument to
that and if they say well there isn't
one we're done you don't know anything
but if they say you know there's
actually two that I have a real problem
with and I think I can answer them what
they're interesting arguments that
person's an intellectual yeah it's funny
because some of my best moments you can
see the way I interview and I'm really I
haven't looked down at the notes once
and I'm trying to hear you and just go
where it feels natural but some of my
best moments on the show I think or
where someone has pinned me into
thinking wait a min I really have to
re-evaluate something and that's how
that's how you evolve and that's how
most of us are and yet we've so let go
of that in the in the public and where
some of its generational a lot of the
young students just have never thought
about the problem of having to learn by
arguing so one of the things that I do
in class and it's it worked better than
I thought was I divide the students into
pairs and they have to choose a question
they're going to debate and then on the
day of the debate the debates are 30
minutes on the day of the debate both of
them hold up big ass yellow dice there's
not enough ritual in our lives right so
you have to hold the dice over your head
and you roll it whoever gets the higher
roll gets to choose which side bah ha I
like that which side you're arguing
until that moment yeah how does a Co it
they love it because they actually they
pay much more attention now to things
they disagree with because they want to
understand it they may have to argue it
do you find that sometimes the ones that
are arguing things they don't believe
actually do a better job because of that
like they are actually true they're do
they have to do more intellectual work
and they're not so emotional where I
have an attachment to a particular
position it's hard for me to explain it
because I just know it's right yeah
whereas if it's not you and I don't
agree with I'm thinking of it logically
step-by-step and I'm presenting evidence
so in a lot of times they end up saying
well that's like
kind of got to change my mind that's not
really what I believed after all or at
least I can see why someone would
believe the opposite that's what
education is yeah so it sounds like your
situation at Duke is pretty good and
maybe they've they've managed to figure
out the free speech thing a little bit
better than most universities Duke is
really committed to it and the thing is
it's not very hard thing to commit to so
our previous president nan cohan's the
best college president I've ever seen
and there was an incident where David
Horowitz had bought this ad about how
reparations for slavery were racist and
you know it was pretty incendiary and I
didn't like the ad I thought it was out
of line but the newspaper the Duke
Chronicle had allowed the David Horowitz
to purchase a one-page ad now he had
done that in a number of newspapers he
did it at Brown University at Brown
University they had a ceremonial burning
of the newspapers on the steps of the
admin building in which the president
participated that's horrible
yeah Duke what nan Cohan said was it's a
newspaper you want to buy an ad go ahead
right that's not a very hard position to
take it's a newspaper I might not have
taken that at his editor I'm not editor
you want to contest it by a net so do
you think that the students or the
faculty or whatever was at Brown when
they do that sort of thing do you think
they realized that they ultimately
strengthen the ideas that they're going
up against so for example I've had David
Horowitz on the show I think he's a
decent guy I agree with him on some
stuff you know you he was a former
leftist and I think thirty years ago was
struggling with a lot of the issues that
I'm thinking about these days but
basically I sat across from my foot he's
a decent guy I didn't think he was some
right-wing maniac or all the things that
they say about him so that when they
then you know burn the newspapers or
whatever and then now you have people
doing a little research on him and then
they may go well this isn't all crazy
what he's saying go look at the reaction
to him then all the what alternative
would be look in the newspaper once in
ologies and together all right that
would be the same if you wasted all that
money they're not persuaded by it do the
hell play yeah I think people are paying
that much attention to newspaper ads you
know well they did after
the people the administration at Brown
burned it that got so much attention
yeah so if nothing else it certainly
does validate two claims one the
university is not capable of holding
legitimate discussions or confrontations
with ideas you disagree with and the
other is I'm going to look at this ad
and see what it says because it's pretty
controversial yeah so we've got about 50
minutes and we really haven't done that
much on economics I do I want to shift a
little bit because to me it seems that
economics if we could get the economic
system to work right whatever that means
but it does resolve a lot of the
political things basically if people
have jobs and can you know buy some
stuff and feel that they own property
and things of that nature that those
other things will become less important
that's my basic beliefs do you think
that's a fair premise to start off with
it's interesting that so many things are
going on at once because the most recent
recent magazine John Nye at George Mason
University has this brilliant article
about inequality so it is true that if
you look at income levels there's more
inequality and the reason is there's
more rich people and the rich have
gained by more than the poor but the
poor gained a lot so but let's compare
this to 1800 in 1800 the mode of
transportation of the wealthy was very
different from the poor now if I'm
really rich maybe I have a Tesla and you
have a Dodge minivan Chevy Equinox least
it's not that different really it has
air conditioning it works pretty well it
gets the road Tesla gets good gas my god
if there's some sort of status
difference but but we're basically doing
the same with the same yeah we've got an
internet connection at home we've got a
nice television
we've got a computer we've got a laptop
we've got a cell phone there are some
differences in status but there's never
been more equality in the basic way that
people live their lives and the
difference in if you look at the
difference in life expectancy between
the wealthy and the poor it used to be
enormous and child mortality rates it
was enormous
it's converged our biggest problem is
not starvation it's obesity
so there's never been a time of greater
equality now I know some people are
going to hear that and go I you liberate
Aryans what he's saying is you people on
the bottom have a TV have a cell phone
have a what about the people that don't
have that stuff now I get what you're
saying those that most of the the bottom
has sort of moved up to have a decent
level but what about that other what's
the libertarian view of how you help or
or not help the people that don't have
that baseline two things one when
historians look back at the period
between 1945 and 2010 the great story is
the worldwide elimination of policy of
poverty through capitalism every country
that has chosen markets has dramatically
improved not just the average but the
least well-off china-india that poverty
is disappearing around the world if by
poverty use some objective measure if
you have a subjective or comparative
measure yes it's a problem because
there's always going to be one-fifth of
the people in the bottom 20% that's just
a definition I'm not a mathematician I
think oh yeah so that's one thing is
allowing markets solves poverty in a way
that no government program ever could
it's better to have a job than a handout
on the other hand I have written quite a
bit about my own support for universal
basic income so I think universal basic
income is a better solution than the
hodgepodge of different intrusive
programs that we have now then let me
explain briefly why so what we have is a
system and I wrote a pretty incendiary
paper about this the state is a bad
polygamist so if you're a single mother
and you have three children if you do
one of two things you'll lose your
support from the polygamist if you get a
job or get married if you actually do
something that achieves some
independence for yourself your husband
the state will stall we're getting a
divorce
right I don't care them you can have
more children you can have affairs but
you have to be committed to me you can
only get support from me
which means that you can't do any of the
things that normally we would expect and
this is a conservative position I
suppose family and jobs are good things
being married and having a job is a good
thing we have what many people even on
the Left have called the cliff effect of
benefits environment section 8 housing
and I get subsidies for food I get
subsidies for school the first 10,000
that I earned costs me twelve thousand
dollars in benefits so the poor aren't
lazy they're rational right so they're
they're really it's just a realistic
game Matt don't learn that always a game
they're not playing a game but it's a
they're making calculations and I am in
that technical sense yeah they have
choices they have strategies those have
payoffs yeah it's unsurprising they pick
the ones that make them better off
because they're desperate they can't
afford to lose this money so for example
if you're living in through subsidized
housing in a decent area with a decent
school and even if you don't want those
handouts well then you realize why I'm
gonna have to work in a job now too and
then they're going to force me to move
to a much worse place to live I can't
afford childcare so the state is a bad
polygamist let's stop doing that and
let's say and another problem as I see
it is minimum wage now the effects of
minimum wage on overall employment
economists debate but it's almost
certainly true that it's very difficult
for people to get a first job or acquire
the experience that allows them to start
the staircase to the American dream and
so the unemployment rate in some urban
areas were like 15 to 25 year-olds is 40
50 percent there's no way for people to
find a first job why do we do that well
you want to say people should be able to
live on this it's not clear why your
first job should be something you should
be able to live on yeah and if you even
bring that up people get upset well
except I say you know you're right
let's make sure they can live let's give
them universal basic income and if they
want to get a job at three dollars an
hour because that's how you get
experience in Europe in Germany if you
serve an apprenticeship you're making
two or three dollars an hour after two
years you have enough experience you can
now get a job that makes $30 an hour so
it's an education
so to me universal basic income that's
given without strength we take the money
that we're spending now which is enough
to give at least $12,000 per poor
people's you take the amount that we
spend divide it by the number where we
take in that from well all of these
different subsidy perks all of the
subsidy programs then go to so we do
including Social Security mm-hmm so we
eliminate all those yeah use that money
to give everyone a universal basic
income and if they get a job they don't
lose it they get married they don't lose
it they can use it for childcare
one of the problems that people have now
is it's very specifically tied to a
location so I can't go somewhere where
there's a job because I won't be able to
establish myself universal basic income
if it's federal means that if I'm living
in Cleveland Ohio I can't find a job and
our jobs in Texas or North Carolina when
I get there I get universal basic income
I can establish myself I can pay for
childcare I can look for a job and
actually our jobs in those places yeah
do you find a conflict between your
libertarian self and your economist self
on this because it seems like the idea
of a libertarian going the state's you
give people money probably seems like
there's some fight there right or if
you're a destination Asst
if I'm a directional list I say dude
we're giving them the money now right
we're already doing it we're already
doing it let's just give the money in a
way that's cheaper and increases liberty
that's the basic directionless document
which is why milton friedman and charles
murray are both in favor of universal
basic income but it has to be a
directional starting we're already doing
that now you're saying we shouldn't do
that great good for you we are and
unless you have some plan to end that
and improve things I'll listen to that
right that's not what they say they just
say well the government shouldn't be
giving out any money it already is let's
do it in a more efficient way and in a
way that increases Liberty because I can
then spend that money on what I actually
want we give these vouchers for food
which I don't really want to buy that I
want to buy something else I sell my
food stamps for 50 cents on the dollar
mm-hmm if I get money I already have a
hundred cents on the dollar now the one
objection that people on the Left when
people on the Left make is well those
poor people
you know how they are they'll spend it
on the wrong stuff so what I want to do
is that he argumented people on the left
make I think that isn't that usually
from the right way no table so they're
going to spend it on them or some people
but at a surprising number of people on
the left believe that yeah so one of the
things I like about this is it sort of
divides the usual political split by um
paternalistic they are there's a whole
bunch of people on the left that really
think experts and honestly rich white
people should be saying here's how these
poor people should be spending their
time and money yeah which is probably
not well that shows you about a lot
about paternalism and authoritarianism a
lot so your next book which is called
tomorrow 3.0 this is sort of partly what
it's going to be about right because
that we're going to about to go into
another revolution which is going to be
a shared economy and technological
revolution and that all sort of plays
into I suppose basic income and just the
way technology is you know iPad to
replace some people at McDonald's this
is just the fact it's interesting so
Marc Andreessen in November 2011 wrote a
piece for The Wall Street Journal in
which he said software eats the world
and what he meant was that software is
to service jobs as robots and automation
are to production so we're used to
thinking of factories as being a
transformation from a bunch of people
putting stuff together to machine's
putting stuff together and it's more
efficient but it means there's fewer
jobs so capitalism almost always reduces
jobs by increasing productivity as the
Trump was wrong and saying that we're
sending jobs to China the whole world is
losing jobs to productivity and that's
good because consumer products are
reduced in price and it means that we're
all wealthier the reason that everyone
almost everyone can afford a car and a
cell phone is that the price of those
things has fallen so much problem is
until now we've said well there's always
the service economy people can always
get service jobs they can't and that's
being hastened by the push for increased
minimum wages so in Seattle for example
if you have a fast
good restaurant you're probably
investigating kiosks so you don't have
to pay $15 an hour to have some guy
really isn't worth $15 an hour at the
front desk right so the service jobs are
going to be taken over by software it's
not clear to me that we're going to be
able to take people who are not
sufficiently well trained by the state
education system to be able to work in
the new economy to make that transition
very quickly so I think universal basic
income you can make a static argument
we're spending the money already mm-hmm
so when might as well spend it more
efficiently but then there's a dynamic
argument to overtime the move to the
sharing economy probably benefits most
of us yeah because we can rent rather
than own prices are going to fall
dramatically we'll need a lot less stuff
the sharing economy just just so people
for the people that don't really get it
so basically that you wouldn't even have
to necessarily own your car that all of
the all of the things that we kind of
have would we figure out better ways to
use them so you wouldn't have to fork
out as much money for them in the first
place
and we'd figure out well I'm going to
use it on Tuesdays at this time and
you're going to use it then and well you
think that day is that the basis or the
example that I always use I think people
recognize it is I have a black BMW 330i
and I'm just the sort of person you
think I am that drives a black BMW 330i
zooming in and out yeah it's a very
expensive car I park it at a special
shrine at my house coaches the door
opens now it's a garage that's pretty
expensive storage and since I worked as
an administrator at Duke for a long time
I have the parking space of God yeah I
can park in a great space so my car is
really expensive and it's always taking
up two pieces of real estate the garage
in my parking space at Duke which is
reserved for me when you multiply that
by I Drive my car 3040 minutes a week
mm-hmm all the rest of time it's just
sitting there I think what's going to
happen 50 years from now is that people
are going to look back and be astonished
at the extent to which we were so
selfish that we wanted to keep stuff so
other people couldn't use it and spend
a lot of money storing it so other
people couldn't use it now to some
extent that gives us status I'm an old
guy I probably have pictures of my
pathetic car on Facebook young people
don't do that they're more interested in
accumulating experiences than they are
stuff so I think that there's a cultural
shift towards a sympathy towards not
having such a big impact on the
environment reducing your footprint so
if a car is constantly in use instead of
sitting in my garage or a parking space
all the time we'll be far fewer of them
we'll be able to have bike lanes because
we won't need to have all this parking
space we won't need to have closets or
storage units where we have all this
crap that we don't even need storage
units are pretty amazing you have all
this stuff that you're not using and you
never go there well but but somebody
else could be using it the reason that
they're not using it is that it's too
difficult for you to find that other
person yeah software is going to change
our ability to find someone to share it
with do you find a little bit that that
can be at odds with individualism that
you're not saying that you wouldn't have
the right to own things right of course
that's not the end conclusion of most
people I think want the use of something
and in our current system owning it is
the cheapest way to have something
available to use but it's fairly common
for I don't have a tuxedo I don't wear
it very often many women have gowns that
they wear maybe once now the reason that
they don't rent the gown is that it's
too difficult to find it in exactly
their size but suppose you had an app
that could take computer or laser
measurements and get exactly the right
measurement and it's delivered to you
two days from now and instead of an $800
gown that you wear once it's $100 rental
and it's a designer gown that would be
great yeah so everything's changing I
think is the theme of this hour there's
a lot changing politically there's a lot
changing economically and we just got to
be smart enough to hopefully not you
know go totally off the ditch as we're
navigating it I'm I'm mostly optimistic
because I think our institutions are
pretty strong and people recognize that
there's a problem
the social media the Internet access to
software all create disruptions but when
you look at human history a lot of the
best things have happened after a period
of disruption but the period disruption
can be pretty bad the 1840s and 50s in
Europe cities were on fire because of
the Industrial Revolution the result was
mostly good so though it's not clear to
me what's going to happen which again is
one of the reasons I'm for universal
basic income let's make sure that those
who are least well-off and who are
through no fault of their own find
themselves not able to work in the
traditional manufacturing jobs that they
expected to be there hmm let's make sure
that there's some minimum on how bad off
they are yeah it says I love the framing
of that because it really is an argument
that transcends the left-right thing
because you're you're hitting them both
that their soft spots so it's got a nice
nice ability to get some people to come
together we'll see that's how Angus you
for more on dr. monger follow him on
Twitter
maybe you'll respond right yo you you do
respond by denies that you wrote a nice
piece on learn liberty about how when
every now and again you have an
experience that actually changes Jen I'm
positive there you go
follow dr. monger on Twitter it's at
Mongoloids
[Music]
you